fast zwei Jahre Krieg ähm Russlands
gegen die Ukraine und während der
Ukraine die Raketen ausgehen hat
Russland heute verkündet die Produktion
von
luftverteidigungsraketen zu verdoppeln
was sagt ihn
das das sagt uns allen dass ähm wie sie
auch schon gesagt haben äh Putin die
russische
Wirtschaft auf Kriegswirtschaft
umgestellt hat und sie haben auch
richtigerweise ergänzt was ich so noch
nie gehört und noch gesagt habe auch die
ganze
Gesellschaft militarisiert auf Krieg ähm
und das hat auch Konsequenzen es hat
dazu oder das hat Konsequenzen in der in
der munitionsverfügbarkeit in der
militärischen Stärke die sich entwickelt
auf russischer Seite und dem gegenüber
hat der Westen seine Hausaufgaben nicht
gemacht bei allem was wir gemacht haben
z.B die Europäische Union hat im März
des letzten Jahres des letzten Jahres
beschlossen eine Million Artillerie äh
äh äh
Munition Munition zu liefern und jetzt
haben wir Ende Januar und es sind gut
300.000 äh geliefert worden 300.000 30%
vor einem Jahr 1 Million versprochen
300.000 geliefert das hat im im Bereich
der
Artilleriemunition dazu geführt dass
inzwischen Russland eine rund fünffache
munitionsüberlegenheit hat 10.000
Artilleriegeschosse gehen von auf
ukrainischenem Boden von russischen
Geschützen auf die Ukraine runter die
Ukraine kann nur noch mit 2000 dagegen
halten das heißt die milit wir haben ein
Stellungskrieg einen
abnutzungskrieg einen fortgehenden
Vernichtungskrieg mit
zunehmender militärischer Dynamik auf
russischer Seite und der Zeitfaktor
liegt günstig eher auf Putins auf
russischer Seite darum ist die Lage die
militärische Lage durchaus kritisch
deckt sich mit dem was sie sag sagen
Verpackung ne die die 2000 Schuss die
die Ukrainer im Moment in der Lage sind
pro Tag sozusagen abzufeuern auf
russische Stellungen das war mal
anders wo wo kommen wir daher von
welchem Niveau und gleich anschließend
die Frage wenn Herr röttkin gerade
zurecht beklagt dass wir eine Menge
Munition versprechen aber dann nicht
liefern woran liegt das also es ist in
der Tat so dass die ukrainische Armee
deutlich sparen muss bei ihrem
arteriebeschuss also sie müssen sich bei
jedem Schuss überlegen sie müssen gut
überlegen ob sie es machen oder nicht
also wir kommen von einem Niveau in der
Offensive letztes Jahr von ungefähr 8000
Schuss pro Tag auch das ist natürlich
geringer als das was die russische Seite
macht aber Sie sehen dass du Unterschied
ursprünglich nicht so groß war man muss
das jetzt eben rationieren und das liegt
eben vor allen Dingen auch daran dass
Russland deutlich besser in der Lage ist
zum einen die eigene Rüstungsproduktion
hochzufahren also wir sehen teilweise
wahrscheinlich bis zu einer
Vervierfachung der Produktion im
artilleriebereich während Europa gerade
mal in der Lage ist das vielleicht 20
bis 30% hoch zu fahren und das ist
natürlich der Unterschied der sich dann
am Ende in der Ukraine bemerkbar macht
und das liegt sicherlich auf
europäischer Seite an ganz
unterschiedlichen Faktoren zum einen ist
man sicher und vielleicht auch zum guten
Grund nicht so bereit die gesamte
Gesellschaft die ganze gesamte
Wirtschaft so auf Krieg umzustellen aber
das muss man ja vielleicht auch gar
nicht einfach um die Rüstungsproduktion
hochzufahren also sie brauchen mehr
europäische Initiativen um zu schauen
dass die
Bestellhöhe oder Masse nicht einfach von
V ich sage mal nationalstaatlichen
erwegung auch von finanziellen erwegung
abhängt wir brauchen mehr Koordination
und wir brauchen natürlich auch
finanziellen also finanzielle Ressourcen
die politisch unterstützt W lass uns
gleich noch mal darüber reden ich würde
gerne weil wir sie heute hier haben Frau
Pung sie kennen Russland ziemlich gut
was passiert da gerade in diesem Land
ich habe das neulich auch so ein
bisschen oberflächig nur gelesen
rüstungserag quasi verdoppelt auf wie
viele Milliarden 130 140 Milliarden
Dollar ja also wir hab genau also zum
einen das wir müssen aber natürlich auch
schauen dass diese Zahlen vielleicht mit
europäischen US-amerikanischen Zahlen
schwer vergleichbar sind weil natürlich
die Kaufkraft in Russland eine ganz
andere ist also das was wir sehen ist in
Effekt eigentlich sogar noch größer plus
wir sehen und das auch das ist etwas was
wir schon über viele Jahre in Russland
sehen dass bestimmte Rüstungs oder
Militärposten in anderen Haushaltsposten
versteckt werden also dann ist die
Subvention für eine Rüstungsfabrik eben
nicht im Militärhaushalt drinne sondern
beispielsweise in dem Haushalt für
regionale Entwicklung also eigentlich
ist die Dynamik noch viel größer und das
ist eben das was Russland gerade diesen
Vorteil verschafft den es in Masse
einfach in der Ukraine hat mhm und wo
sind diese Fabriken ich l von von von
Sibirien dass man dort irgendwie
besonders viele Rüstungsbetriebe
hochzieht und zweiter Punkt auch
interessant sozusagen in der
militärischen Tradition von Stalin sich
wirklich konzentriert auf das was
offensichtlich in der Ukraine an der
Front funktioniert und alles andere
systematisch
weglässt also wir sehen und auch da
müssen wir natürlich sagen dass wir
Zusagen diese Rüstungsproduktion
eigentlich nur indirekt nachverfolgen
können weil Russland keine Zahlen dazu
veröffentlicht sondern wir können uns
anschauen beispielsweise in welchen
Regionen geht die Wirtschaftsleistung
besonders hoch und dann sehen wir dass
dort vor allen Rüstungsbetriebe sind das
ist beispielsweise Moskau herum dort
werden sehr stark Raketen produziert wir
haben auch mehrere Fabrik rund um
katharinenburg beispielsweise und das
sind dann eben auch die Regionen in
denen wir ein deutsche deutliches
Wirtschaftswachstum sehen und das ist ja
ganz interessant vor allen Dingen weil
es teilweise auch Regionen sind die
durch die
Sanktionen durch also durch die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung insgesamt
eigentlich verloren haben das heißt die
Rüstungsproduktion ist nicht nur für den
Zuwachs zuständig sondern auch
verantwortlich für das Ausgleichen
eigentlich von Wegfallen von anderen
Industrieproduktion beispielsweise im
Automobilsektor
ja äh ja sehr gelitten hat mhm und die
Frage der der Rekrutierung die Frage wie
viele Männer kannst du immer weiter
mobilisieren ähm ich hatte letzten
November die Gelegenheit russische
Kriegsgefangene zu sprechen und ich war
überrascht davon
wie viele von denen aus Gefängnissen
tatsächlich kommen sehr viele aus
abgelegenen Regionen btien und so weiter
äh das heißt weitesgehend menschenlehre
Regionen oder Leben nicht viele Menschen
das heißt kann auch keine große Bewegung
entstehen gegen die die fernen Eliten
irgendwo in Moskau oder in St Petersburg
das sozusagen psychologisch clever
gemacht der dritte Punkt war dass ich
das Gefühl hatte es gibt so eine
Ökonomie des Todes in Russland es lohnt
sich zu sterben also wir sehen in der
Tat dass und auch das ist wieder etwas
was wir indirekt nachverfolgen müssen
aber dass wir vor allen Dingen Soldaten
sehen aus
entlegenenden Regionen aus Gefängnissen
aus sozial schwachen Bereichen das ist
natürlich auch eine absichtsvolle
Strategie weil die Moskau Regierung bei
der ersten Mobilisierung gesehen hat wie
unbeliebt das ist und da eben sehr
vorsichtig sein muss und das heißt eben
wenn man es ganz zynisch formuliert und
zusammenrechnet wie viel höher das sollt
als der Durchschnittslohn in Russland
ist also Durchschnittslohn liegt
ungefähr bei 700 800 € der soll für
jeden Monat an der Front liegt bei über
2000 also da sehen sie den Unterschied
plus sie bekommen Zahlung wenn sie
verwundet werden sie bekommen natürlich
Zahlung für die Familie wenn sie
gefallen werden die Familien bekommen
danach auch Zahlung man könnte eben
zynisch sagen gerade für ärmere Familien
lohnt sich ein Soldat der am Ende stirbt
mehr als W die Person leben
würde zurück nach Deutschland Herr
rotgen warum ist im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss die Diskussion über Taurus
gestrichen
worden wir setzen die Diskussion seit
vielen Sitzungswochen das sind in
seit Monaten auf die
Tagesordnung die Koalition ist gespalten
darin also Taurus zu liefern weil es
eine wesentliche Stärkung und ein
wesentlicher deutscher Beitrag wäre
diesen hochwirksamen marchchlugkörper
500 km Reichweite zu liefern wir haben
einen Antrag gestellt und die Koalition
setzt den jedes Mal ab gerade heute
morgen wieder abgesetzt
die FDP ist dafür die Grünen sind dafür
eine Mehrheit dafür im Deutschen Bund
Mischung aus Unwilligkeit bei der SPD
beim Kanzler und mangelndem Rückgrad bei
Grünen und FDP genau das habe ich im
Deutschen Bundestag genauso gesagt also
der Kern ist dass der Bundeskanzler das
nicht will und auch die Mehrheit der SPD
will es nicht warum will er das nicht da
fängt es an der Bundeskanzler spricht ja
nicht mit uns also mit der Bevölkerung
auch nicht mit dem Bundestag er
begründet das nicht er sagt das nicht
mal es gibt seit Monaten aus reden ähm
und darum können wir nur
spekulieren meine These ist er will es
nicht weil es so wirksam ist der
Bundeskanzler hat ja bei jedem
Waffensystem es fing an mit schützenpanz
da hat er damals noch beim Spiegel in
einem Interview die Lieferung von
Schützenpanzern mit dem nuklearen
eskalationsrisiko problematisiert das
heißt der hat sich das angstnarrativ das
nukleare angstnarrativ
Putins selber als Deutscher Bundes pzer
zu eigen gemachttim ist aber lange her
mus sag lang aber es fing bei einem
Schützenpanzer an dann ging es bei den
Haubitzen weiter sie werden sich an die
leidige lähmende Diskussion um den
Leopard 2 um die Panzer erinnern und die
eigentlich so das so und das braucht die
Ukraine wenn sie sich verteidigen können
soll sie kriegt es zu wenig und der der
der marschbkorper Taurus der deutsche
fliegt weiter als die anderen britischen
französischen als Skype und genau fliegt
weiter und er würde es den Ukrainern
eben erlauben nicht so nah an die
Frontlinie heranzurücken um russische
Waffen und Munition zu zerstören bevor
sie Zivilisten in der Ukraine tötet und
zerstört und nach meiner nach meiner
Interpretation hat der Bundeskanzler
eine andere
Russlandpolitik es geht bei ihm um
Russlandpolitik und hat eine andere Idee
der zukünftigen Rolle Russlands in
Europa als die Mehrheit des Deutschen
Bund Tages sie hat mhm ich glaube dass
der Bundeskanzler auch mit der Mehrheit
der SPD immer noch der Auffassung ist
dass bei allem was geschehen ist
Russland für die Sicherheit Europas mm
wichtiger war ist und bleibt als all die
Staaten zwischen Deutschland und
Russland und darum hat er will er nie
und will bei dieser wirksamsten Waffe
unbedingt nicht dass sie geliefert wird
weil das wiederum dann das Tischtuch
auch von ihm und Deutschland zu Russland
zerschneiden würde und das will er im
Hinblick auf zukünftige Vorstellungen
vermeiden er sagt ja auch nicht die
Ukraine soll gewinnen er sagt die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren Russland
darf nicht gewinnen er ist im Grunde
seine politische Formel ist im Grunde
drückt sich jetzt in dem militärischen
Pad das wir haben aus und ich glaube
seine Vorstellung ist die des Pad und
dann kommen irgendwann Verhandlungen die
das Problem lösen das ist meine
Interpretation aber es ist eigentlich
ein Skandal dass wir hier sitzen und
rätseln was ist eigentlich der Gedanke
und die Politik des Kanzlers wobei ich
tatsächlich glaube es gibt
vielschichtigere Gründe als diesen den
sie nennen der spielt sicher auch eine
Rolle aber es gibt ja auch handfeste
operative Gründe juristische Gründe die
offensichtlich im Kanzleramt diskutiert
werden anders wo auch nenn sie sagen sie
den beispielsweise ist ja umstritten ob
man für Taurus ein bundestagsman ein
Bundestagsmandat bräuchte weil man
Soldaten in die Ukraine schicken müsste
um Daten zu programmieren und so weiter
ich weiß es gibt unterschiedliche
Lesarten diesbezüglich aber das ist
offenkundig ein Grund ich referiere nur
sousagen die möglichen Gründe
natürlich anderen abräumen vielleicht
antworten sie kurz Herr rötken und dann
der dann machen sie weiter Herr Medik
wenn das okay ist also erstmal es wird
es wird seit Monaten werden
unterschiedliche dann inzwischen fallen
gelassene zum Teil widersprüchliche
Begründung genannt die schon deshalb
Ausreden sind aber das wurde das zählte
zu den Ausreden die mal eine Weile
genannt wurden seit zwei Monaten wird
das nicht mehr genannt weil inzwischen
klar ist die Aussage dass man für die
Lieferung dieses marschflugkörpers ein
bundeswehrmandat bräuchte in Parenthese
der Bundestag würde es sofort geben der
Bundestag würde es sofort geben ist aber
ist aber ist inzwischen ist inzwischen
geklärt dass das nicht der Fall ist Hal
ist juristisch unhalar keine deutschen
Soldaten dahinchicken dann zu
programmieren nein es müssen ke nein es
müssen kein nein es müssen keine und das
ist auch die rote Linie die die Union
auch ganz sich sich erhalten will gr
natürlich ne beim Vergleich
selverständlich wir nicht Kriegspartei
werden und es kommt zu keinem Einsatz
und nebenbei noch mal es gibt eine
Mehrheit des Deutschen Bundestag CDU CSU
FDP und Grüne sind dafür der Deutsche
Bundestag ist dafür der Kanzler will es
nicht und sucht die ganze Zeit Ausreden
und juristische Argumente eignen sich
immer prima um Nebel zu bilden und die
Sache zu ver ich glaub gibt zwei andere
zwei andere Gründe noch der eine ist
sozusagen liegt in Scholz selbst
begründet das ist so eine gewisse Form
der Bockigkeit ja die man ja immer
wieder auch bei ihm feststellen kan
Bockigkeit ist das jetzt die Kategorie
bei dem Thema also sozusagen in seiner
gesamten politischen Laufbahn würde ich
sagen auch in der Außenpolitik in der
ukrainepolitik ist das immer
wieder ja sichtbar dass er sagt also je
mehr ich gedrängt werde desto weniger
tue ich es ja das kann man jetzt
kindisch finden pubertär gehört aber
absolut zu Olaf sch würden nicht die
Qualität eines Argumentes beimessen ich
versuche nur sozusagen zu ergründen
warum
genau dann gibt es aber glaube ich ein
größeres Argument was gerade im
Entstehen ist und das ist dass er
natürlich die tauruslieferung als Hebel
sieht um europäische Partner unter Druck
zu setzen mehr zu tun und ich muss sagen
da kann ich ihn ein Stück weit
Nachvollziehen der wir machen das wenn
ihr auch nee eher nach dem Motto wir
machen so viel ihr kündigt immer an ihr
fordert immer aber ihr macht nichts und
es gibt da schon gewisses Missverhältnis
in Europa wenn man sich das mal
quantitativ anguckt wir sind das
wichtigste und größte Geberland und
helferland für die Ukraine bei weit bei
weiten in Europa ja mit großem Abstand
zu Platz 2 und ich finde angesichts der
bröckelnden des bröckelnden Rückhalts in
Europa in den USA angesichts des
Stillstands an der Front in in der
Ukraine finde ich es plausibel aus Sicht
des Kanzlers zu sagen Leute wir müssen
uns hier schon gemeinsam ansprengen
anstrengen das kann nicht nur an uns
hängen ja und ich glaube dass das ein
Argument ist was gerade eher kultiviert
okay ich w eine Sache was irgendwie
wichtig ist also ich halte Olaf Scholz
kann man vieles nachsagen in Sachen
Kommunikation und so aber für ein
absoluten Profi mm und jemand der
wirklich versucht sein Job so gut wie
möglich zu machen ich ich kann dem
Argument sagen dem psychologisierenden
Argument das ist irgendwie so eine Art
von Sturheit und Bockigkeit bei dem
Thema halt ich für komplett
ausgeschlossen ne das war ja aber bei
bei den unterschiedlichsten
Waffensystemen was ja immer wieder der
Fall angesichts der Lage gerade es
versteht jeder kann man ich weiß also es
halt nicht Kategorie es wäre aber in der
Sache das letzte was sie sagen ist ja
völlig absurd zu sag also erstens
liefern alle Europäer zu wenig man kann
sagen wir die anderen liefern noch mehr
zu wenig als wir aber die Lage haben wir
ja am Anfang geschildert die die Ukraine
hat kein Material mehr und allein
Deutschland hat die doppelte
Wirtschaftskraft als Russland die
Europäer zusammen ein Vielfaches m so
und wir können nicht das was die die die
Hälfte unserer Wirtschaftsleistung sind
erbringen also das heißt es liegt nur am
Willen und wir jetzt haben wir für 4
Milliarden Waffen geliefert im letzten
Jahr 4 Milliarden das ist einerseits
eine große Zahl nicht das 49 € Ticket
kostet 3 Milliarden für die öffentliche
Hand so das ist ungefähr die Dimension
aber es geht nicht um 4 Milliarden 3
oder 7 Milliarden es geht darum dass der
Krieg besiegt wird dass der Krieg aus
Europa vertrieben wird und da kann ich
doch nicht sagen ich liefere etwas ganz
Wichtiges nicht und nehme die Ukraine
und ihre mangelnde
Verteidigungsfähigkeit und ihr ausbluten
und ihr sterben als Geisel um vielleicht
hern Maron zu motivieren dass er mehr
tut das wäre doch völlig absurd wenn er
so vorgehen würde so haben sie es ja
geschildt ich habe auch gar keine Lust
sozusagen den Olaf Scholz Verteidiger
hier zu Spen aber ja ich versuche ja zu
ergründen was die sozusagen was die
Gründe sein könnten aber sie würden auch
nicht behaupten dass sozusagen sich
jetzt die Lage an der Front durch dieses
eine Waffensystem verändert oder es ist
ja da es ist schon vor
nein ist nicht es ist eben nicht da es
ist schon da Taurus ein vergleichbares
nein ist nicht Vergleich es ist ein mal
kurz erklären also sie sie sie deuten
damit an Skyp und Storm ne die beiden
markörper von Briten und Franzosen die
baugleich
sindü nur darum Z sind aber anders als
Taurus weil Taurus ist bunkerbrechend
Taurus kann meh war warum könnte das
strategisch so wichtig sein also es sind
zwei
Elemente die der Ukraine gefehlt haben
bei ihrer Offensive auf eigenem
Territorium und mit diesen zweielen
Elementen würde keine westliche
Regierung die eigene Armee jemals in
eine offensive schicken nämlich eine
reine Bodenoffensive ohne
Luftunterstützung und ohne reichweitende
der Raketen oder Marschflugkörper um
Logistik zu zerstören ohne diese beiden
Elementen Elemente war war die Ukraine
der der den Angriffen aus der der Luft
und der Gegenwehr der Russen
ausgeliefert die sich einbarrikadiert
hatten mit Panzersperren mit
Minenfeldern und so weiter so das und
darum sind ist es eine ist es eine ist
es eine Komponente die strategische
Bedeutung hat dass man nicht immer nah
an die Front heran muss wo man zerstört
getroffen und getötet wird sondern aus
einer weiten Entfernung 500 km ist
dieser marchblurkörper mit einer enormen
durchschlagswirkung äh und beides haben
die anderen von der Franzosen und der
brittenen so nicht die haben eine
geringere etwas mehr als die Hälfte der
Reichweite und sind nicht so wirksam
also es ist schon wichtig aber dieses
Argument hört man doch wirklich seit
seit jetzt fast zwei Jahren bei jedem
neuen Waffensystem ja das hat ist eine
strategische Komponente elementar
wichtig um den Krieg zu drehen die
Dynamik zu verändern hören wir immer und
es passiert aber am Ende nicht ja wir
enden an der Front wie wir jetzt da
stehen ja weil es nicht geliefert wird
ich meine nur weil es schon lange F
sozusagen die Verengung die Verengung
auf so ein Waffensystem ist schwierig
ist eine absolute Verengung doch klar
kein also es ist ein Element der
Unzulänglichkeit in der Unterstützung
wie ich habe eben gesagt eine Millionen
Schuss artilleriunition wird nicht warum
denn nicht
der Scholz mit vier anderen
Premierministern beklagt sich heute in
der Financial Times es müssen
industriekapazitäten gebaut werden er
ist ja kein Artikelschreiber ist doch
Bundeskanzler warum hat er das nicht der
Krieg wird fast 2 Jahre alt warum macht
er es nicht warum entscheidet er nicht
warum erweitert er nicht die
rüstungskapazitäten im konventionellen
Bereich im für Munition ist doch alles
möglich reine Fehlen des politischen
Willens nichts anderes ich finde es gibt
ja gerade wirklich wahnsinnig viele
Gründe den Kanzler zu kritisieren und
man schlägt teilweise die Hände überm
Kopf zusammen wenn man sich die
Verfassung dieser Bundesregierung
anguckt und die Performance ja das ist
fragt man sich was in dieser
Kanzlerschaft eigentlich los ist aber
ausgerechnet das Feld der ukraineeptik
würde ich sagen ist eher eine Stärke von
ihm ja warum das Ergebnis spricht nicht
für die Stärke die Ukraine ist in der
Defensive sie blutet aus
Krieg ist auf einem jetzt leicht
erfolgreichen Kurs aber wenn sie
behaupten es liegt sozusagen daran dass
ein bestimmtes Waffensystem das etwas zu
verkürzte Argument ist ja nicht meine
These das gehört dazu und die Mängel und
die Unzulänglichkeit ist in der Breite
vorhanden es ist viel zu wenig was wir
lief wird gerne noch mal Frau P an dem
Punkt Fragen damit man das mal versteht
Taurus haben gerade gesagt enorme
Durchschlagskraft über 1000 kmh schnell
es kann sozusagen reagieren auf auf auf
die Frage was ist das für ein Ziel dass
ich gerade treffe also entsprechend
verändert sich auch die die Sprengkraft
geht immer wieder ich weiß nicht ob wir
eine Karte zeigen können um die um den
Zugang zuur Krim die sogenannte
kerschbrücke über die ein großer Teil
der Logistik der russischen Logistik
läuft das mit mit Taurus könnte man
diese Brücke so zerstören dass die
russische Logistik empfindlich getroffen
werden würde erster Teil der Frage und
zweiter Teil hab dieser Tage von
jemandem erfahren der sagte es ist sogar
noch sehr viel bitterer die Russen
nutzen jetzt diese fehlende
Angriffskraft in Sachen kerzschbrücke um
weitere logistikstränge zu bauen
Eisenbahnlinien neu zu verlegen damit
man noch besser russische Armee ist eine
eisenbahnarmee traditionell immer
gewesen noch besser seine Waffen da
reinbringen kann was können Sie uns
darüber sagen also vielleicht
grundsätzlich noch mal festzustellen
warum diese Fähigkeit egal ob jetzt die
bisschen stärkere Fähigkeit des Taurus
ist oder die bisschen schwächere
Fähigkeit beispielsweise des britischen
Storm shadows ist es in der Tat so dass
es genauso wie schützen oder Kampfpanzer
nicht die eine Waffe ist die den ganzen
Krieg verändern sind glaub ich auch alle
einig ne genau aber die Frage ist welche
Rolle kann sie vor allenen jetzt für das
kommende Jahr in der Ukraine spielen
also wir haben gesehen dass die
Offensive gescheitert ist die
ukrainischen Truppen haben
materialproblem sie haben aber auch ein
Personalproblem nicht nur weil sie
Zusagen mehr Menschen mobilisieren
müssen was immer schwerer wird in der
Ukraine ähm und sondern weil sie die ja
brauchen um Truppen zu rotieren wir
haben Truppen die dezimiert sind die
einfach müde sind die die Urlaub
brauchen ganz um das ganz einfach zu
sagen und das müssen sie sozusagen in
diesem Jahr bewältigen gleichzeitig die
Materialien heranschaffen um
möglicherweise neue offensivkapazitäten
zu haben und das machen sie während die
Russen versuchen den Druck hochzuhalten
um genau das zu verhindern und da kann
es eben eine sehr nützliche Fähigkeit
sein tief
und quasi in die russischen
logistiklinien hineinzuwiken das ist vor
allen die kerzchbrücke aber das ist sie
natürlich nicht nur sondern auch ganz
unterschiedliche Versorgungs und
logistiklinien an Land also eben nicht
über diese Brücke und die können Sie
damit treffen es ist natürlich aber auch
so jetzt bin ich nicht ganz sicher ich
glaube Deutschland verfügt ungefähr über
200 Taurus davon sind vielleicht die
Hälfte einsatzbereit wenn ich das
richtig Kopf habe nälich die nächste
interessante fr also da kann ich mich da
kann ich mich auch da kann wie den
wissen wir das wie viele haben wir von
denen also wir haben ein paar hundert
und 600 kann das sein genau weiß gar
nicht wie geheim diese Zahlen sind aber
die dürfen das ja sagen ich hab das
gehört
erfahren wir
Kön das ist erfreulich dass es die
gibt wir könnten eine signifikante Zahl
liefern und
der 100 sicher mal 100 50 sicher mal und
das wäre schon was und der
geschäftsfürer dieser Firma hat gesagt
wir sind nebenbei bemerkt sagte er in
der Lage zu produzieren wir würden nur
gern wissen ob ihr sie wollt aber wir
können produzieren und das dauert nicht
so lange das ist in Monaten geschehen
jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich an dem
Punkt eine eine eine Frage herkin ich
meine sie sagen jetzt der Kanzler will
das nicht die SPD will das nicht ihr
eigene Leute wollen das zum Teil auch
nicht den Taurus ja lief das ist
jedenfalls mal in der Bundestagsfraktion
ein einstimmiger Beschluss in der
Bundestagsfraktion Bundestagsfraktion
ist das in der sächsischen
Fraktion das weiß ich nicht wie es in
der sächsischen Fraktion
g gut informierte Quellen aber
jedenfalls jedenfalls ist gut
informierten Kreise sagen wir dass
jemand wie Michael kretschm z.B der
sächsische Ministerpräsident
Ministerpräsident will auf gar kein Fall
das ist richtig der hat auch eine andere
grundsätzlich andere Position dieser
Frage kann man glaube ich so sagen aber
es ist eine bundespolitische
Entscheidung und
die
Bundestagsfraktion die darüber zu
entscheiden hätte und diesen Antrag
gestellt hat hat es einstimmig
beschlossen mal ganz kurz sagen ich bin
ganz klar gegen die Lieferung von
Marschflugkörpern sagt Michael kretschm
wollen wir wirklich in Kauf nehmen dass
deutsche Raketen in Russland einschlagen
könnten und daraufhin Roderich
Kiesewetter den sie auch bestens kennen
ihr verteidigungspolitischer
Experte echt hart reagiert ich weiß gar
nicht ob er den den Tweet da hab auf auf
X Vals Twitter warum nimmst du Kretsch
mal hin dass Achtung infinan Chips aus
Sachsen in russischen Raketen
ukrainische Kinder töten und Familien
zerstören warum hast du eine doppelte
Moral drei Ausrufezeichen ich bin
enttäuscht wie entsetzt und er spielt an
auf eine Recherche ich glaub der der
Kollegen von der
sonntagsfz also der
FAS die nachgewiesen haben dass sich
Chips offensicht von infinan in Dresden
hergestellt in russischen Raketen
wiederfinden um diese an sich eigentlich
dummen Raketen dann smart und schlau zu
machen so wie gehen wir damit um also
sind ja zwei Punkte erstmal zum Taus bin
ich der Auffassung von von Roderich
Kiesewetter aber wie wie gehen Sie mit
dieser mit dieser und das andere ist
noch nichta in der eigenen Partei um na
ja was indem wir klare also wir Kön die
Bundestagsfraktion kann nicht mehr als
klar Position beziehen ich glaube bin
auch auch ganz sicher das ist die
Position der CDU und der CSU als
Parteien dass Michael kretschm äh dort
eine grundsätzlich kann man sagen andere
Position vertritt auch was das
Verhältnis zu Russland anbelangt ist
bekannt wird von Roderich Kiesewetter
von mir von anderen kritisiert aber er
bleibt bei seiner harsch kritisiert ja
weil es auch eine falsche also wirklich
auch eine Falschbehauptung war die
aufgestellt hat denn einer der Punkte
die ja auch sozusagen mal kritis oder
kritisch angemerkt wurden ist dass es
sozusagen der deutschen Programmierung
dieses marschflugkörpers Bedarf und
schon damit ist ausgeschlossen dass das
äh oder ist Gesich sichergestellt dass
es nur auf ukrainischem Territorium
eingesetzt wird und zweitens sichert die
Ukraine das auch zu auch bei anderen
Waffen und sie hat sich B auch auch
immer dran gehalten also das ist ein ein
Misstrauen und auch eine tatsächliche
falschbehhauptung die nicht okay ist was
die Chips anbelangt das ist auch ein
Punkt den wir als Union
kritisieren dass wir nämlich in unserem
Sanktionsregime gegenüber Russland viel
zu viele Lücken lassen die Sanktionen
sind gewissermaßen wie ein Zaun und
dieser Zaun hat erstens Löcher und
zweitens gibt es ihn in manchen
Bereichen gar nicht und das sind
sogenannte dual use Güter also Chips
kütig
se aber jeder weiß wenn ich dir wenn ich
das liefere als Haushaltsgegenstand der
auch schlau ist kann ich das auch da
rausnehmen und in die Rakete
reinpflanzen und meine Überzeugung oder
meine Auffassung unsere politische
Auffassung ist dass wir das
sanktionieren sollten und solche Güter
nicht nach Russland liefern sollten das
ist unverantwortlich weil sie dort töten
und kriegsbestandteil sind Frau Packung
ich glaube ich glaube gar nicht dass das
politisch in Frage gestellt wird was sie
gerade gesagt haben Herr RotK sondern
das Problem ist ja viel mehr die
Umsetzung also was wir was wir sehen
egal ob es ja Chips sind oder auch
andere Güter ist ja nicht dass sie
direkt dir häufig nicht direkt
exportiert werden die Gefälle gibt's
auch weil die sind dann eben auch
strafrechtlich relevant im Zweifelsfall
sondern dass sie über Drittländer gehen
insbesondere Kasachstan beispielsweise
Türkei Golfstaaten spielen da eine große
R das ist natürlich sehr sehr schwer
nachzuverfolgen weil sie verkaufen das
dann nach Kasachstan und die verkaufen
das dann weiter und dann müssten sie um
das sinnvoll zu unterbinden eben diese
Firmen oder diese Personen in diesen
Drittstaaten sanktionieren was enorm
aufwendig ist und da die
Sanktionspolitik vor allen auf
europäischer Ebene liegt haben dafür
eigentlich gar nicht auf europäischer
Ebene die Ressourcen dafür und es ist
natürlich auch die Frage wenn sie dann
anfangen Drittstaaten zu sanktionieren
was macht das mit der politischen
Unterstützung für die Ukrain in diesen
Staaten ja aber die ist in diesen
Staaten ohne also erstmal du jugüter
müss die haben wir nicht in
ausreichendem Maße sanktioniert als
Europäische Union und das andere sind
diese bekannten Drittstaaten wo auf
einmal die Exporte bestimmter Produkte
die deren Export wir nach Russland
verbieten
dann auf einmal in 1000% mehr in diese
Länder geliefert werden und jeder Mann
weiß dass es eine bewusste und
eindeutige Umgehung unserer eigenen
sanktionsvorschriften ist also müssen
sie jetzt auch eingehalten und umgesetzt
werden und einen solch offenkundigen
Missbrauch
dieser Möglichkeit in bestimmte Länder
zu liefen müssen dann unterbunden werden
wenn ich das als eine These mal
zusammenfassen darf es muss uns einfach
mal klar werden was hier auf dem Spiel
steht
das ist nicht irgendeine
wirtschaftsrechtliche Regelung ob du
oder was auch immer es geht hier um
Krieg und wenn dieser Krieg sich lohnt
wenn er sich durchsetzt dann wird der
Krieg in Europa bleiben mit allen
Konsequenzen er wird sich ausdehnen er
wird näher uns herankommen Krieg ist der
absolute Ernstfall der Politik und wir
müssen ihn als solchen wirklich
begreifen wir tun es in der Fläche nicht
glau ein Stück weit dass wir ein Stück
weit an der muss ich jetzt mal sagen an
der Psyche dieses also unseres Landes
auch vorbei diskutieren aber ist es an
der Realität vorbei damit fängt's ja mal
an mit der Realität interessz meinen
Punkt
machen ich glaube dass wir da schon auch
an dem Kipppunkt stehen ja dass viele
Deutsche interessiert wie kommen wir
eigentlich aus diesem Krieg raus und wie
endet das Ganze ja und ich finde
zumindest diese Frage hat eine
Berechtigung und die wird die wird
absolut zu wenig diskutiert und
ich glaube dass wir das sehen ja in in
immer wieder regelmäßigen Umfragen zetzt
im Deutschland Trend über 50% der
deutschen finden dass wir diplomatisch
zu wenig machen ich teile das nicht aber
ich referiere sozusagen diese diese
Umfrage wir sehen die gesellschaftliche
Stimmung in Ostdeutschland die ist da
teilweise noch viel deutlicher und viel
krasser die Distanz zum Kriegs viel
größer und deswegen kann ich Herrn
kretschm Position J der infinionage
absolut echt den Versuch einer
diplomatischen Berechtigung sozusagen in
der Debatte Frage zitieren darf hier 51%
der Befragten ja ein paar Wochen her 51%
der Befragten sagen wir sollten mehr
liefern 30% sagen da ist gerade richtig
20% falsch also es ist nicht so dass die
Bevölkerung nicht kapiert wie der Ernst
der Lage ist die Politik darum Z Psyche
die Psyche der Bevölkerung hat sich
stark geändert die Psyche der Politik
wenig ich nehme wahr dass sich gerade
reihweise politische Parteien neu
gründen ja die alle dieses Gefühl
abholen und das kann doch nicht unser
Interesse sein dass dieses Gefühl nach
sozusagen wie geht's eigentlich da
weiter wie geht das aus wann kommt der
von Extremisten abgeholt wird das kann
nicht sein ja das Fin ich mus in der
Debatte der etablierten Partei gerne
einmal Michael kretchm zitieren der sagt
es kann sein dass die Ukraine bei einem
Waffenstillstand erst einmal hinnehmen
muss die Formulierung ist wie
spektakulär dass gewisse Territorien für
die Ukraine vorübergehend nicht
erreichbar sind
was meint er damit ich glaube da treffen
ja aber auch ein bisschen
innenpolitische Bedürfnisse auf
außenpolitische Realitäten also ich
würde sagen Sie haben ja im Grunde
genommen beide recht aber das Problem
aus meiner Sicht ist dass wir über sehr
unterschiedliche Sachen diskutieren wir
haben zum einen eine Realität im Krieg
gegen die Ukraine die Verhandlung nach
wie vor aus meiner Sicht zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt als nicht realistisch
erscheinen lassen zumindest keine
ernsthaften Verhandlung weil wir haben
es vorhin angesprochen ist die diese
gesellschaftliche wirtschaftliche
politische Mobilisierung und
Radikalisierung in Russland gibt
eigentlich keine Bereitschaft für einen
echten Kompromiss ist tatsächlich ein
wichtiger Punkt ja der darüber hinaus
geht okay wir machen jetzt mal kurz eine
Pause damit wir halben Jahr noch stärker
angreifen
können und das worüber viele Menschen in
Deutschland nachdenken und ich glaube
das ist ein Problem was uns verstärkt
begleiten wird ist ja die Verbindung zu
Innenpolitik also nicht nur welche
Projektionsfläche hat
außcht das anspricht ja reden wir
eigentlich über vielleicht die
Unzufriedenheit der Menschen gerade auch
in Ostdeutschland mit dem System was wir
in Deutschland haben ist es vielleicht
das was sie ausdrücken wollen oder ist
es eben auch die Angst wir sehen das
jetzt ja mit ja einem einem verstärkten
Verteilungskampf einfach aufgrund der
schrumpfenden Wirtschaft der Budgetkrise
man fragt sich okay die geben wir das
Geld jetzt aus für Digitalisierung für
den Krieg für Bildung für sie könnten
Liste
verlängern und da kommen wir natürlich
in Konflikte und ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt dass Außenpolitik vor allen
Dingen besser erklärt werden muss und
auch das Verständnis der Menschen dafür
wie Außenpolitik funktioniert verbessert
werden muss also nicht ich fliege jetzt
mal nach Moskau und dann so trumpmäßig
Handel ich da was aus und dann wird das
Ding schon laufen dass das halt einfach
so in der Form nicht möglich ist
mM wir reden die ganze Zeit über diesen
Krieg ähm vielleicht hilft es weil
Bilder eine andere Kraft haben
gelegentlich vielleicht können die
Kollegen aus der Regie mal letzte
aktuelle Bilder aus hkif mal zuspielen
einfach mal klar zumachen was dort in
der Ukraine gerade Tag für Tag passiert
das ist aktuell sozusagen
Lebenswirklichkeit in
chiv eine Stadt die im vergangenen
Herbst noch als als wir dort unterwegs
waren für Dreharbeiten als relativ
sicher gehilte sagt was auf wenn ihr
nach Haki fährt da ist die Situation
einigermaßen unter Kontrolle wenige
Wochen und Monate später sieht's da so
aus das ist die Realität dieses Krieges
ähm und ich glaube auch auf einen
Umstand muss man Hinweisen in dem
Zusammenhang der in der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit hermeedik würde ich sagen
nie so richtig diskutiert wird also wir
ich ich verstehe Vorbehalte gegen Waffen
ich verstehe die Vorbehalte gegen die
Konzentration einer solchen Masse von
Waffen im Zentrum von Europa auch die
Frage in wessen Händen sind diese Waffen
in wessen Händen geraten sie
möglicherweise irgendwann alles Themen
aber die Tatsache
dass viele und in dem Fall dann
Millionen Ukrainer auf zu einer Sache
niemals bereit wären wenn dieser Krieg
verloren geht werden die nicht unter
russischer Herrschaft leben weil jeder
von denen Horrorgeschichten zu erzählen
hat entweder aus der eigenen oder aus
anderen Familien von Vergewaltigungen
Folterkellern Hinrichtungen
Grausamkeiten der übelsten Art jeder in
der Ukraine erzählt ihnen sehr glaubhaft
solche Geschichten das heißt wir haben
dann Millionen von Menschen im Zweifel
die vor unseren Türen stehen V unseren
europäischen Türen darüber reden wir
sehr sehr wenig über das ist nur eine
der Konsequenzen die drohen wenn dieser
Krieg verloren geht würden Sie dem
zustimmen klar ich glaube sozusagen ich
glaube auch dass deutsche mit einer
großen Zerrissenheit sozusagen auf
diesen Krieg gucken ne also weil viele
da haben sie ja auch rech Röken viele
sagen sich natürlich was wir auf gar
keinen Fall zulassen können ist dass der
Eindruck entsteht der Putin kan einfach
so einen kleinen Teil der Ukraine
einverleiben ja dann marschiert er
einfach ins nächste Land ist
ausgeschlossen gleichzeitig guckt man
natürlich auf solche Bilder und denkt
sich das kann ja auch nicht auf ewig
weitergehen ja also es ist schon eine
wahnsinnige Emotionalisierung auch
unserer Gesellschaft natürlich die
dieser KR Krieg in der unmittelbaren
Nachbarschaft auslöst